[Music]
all right so let's talk about this gamma
tool chain this is I'm a little time
talking about this alright
this is a diagram of the same per cubic
in the previous slide okay but I just
wanted to be able to provide you with a
few other things I love skate better
this sweet [ __ ] okay so um in this
category of tools you know this this is
providing a provider template you should
have something that monitors application
performance and hardware components you
should have tools that allow you to
release into production you should have
tools that allow you to deal with
configuration management you should have
ways of ensuring accurate good code
development and unit tests you should
have tools that build applications right
sometimes application comes from
multiple source files and so on having
the tool that knows where to go to get
everything is really important and then
you need to be able to form integration
and performance testing right Givaudan
lastly just simply packaging the
application so there's a concept called
continuous integration and continuous
deployment it's this notion that as code
makes it in as the changes are submitted
for approval
and they are approved that code is
automatically tested and integrate it
with the books given in the chat it has
integrated with the application all
right so so we have a couple of
questions where does regression testing
fit into this
I think regression testing can be done
either it can be done in several places
probably
first stop might be when building the
application yes exactly
yeah exactly yogi between building and
immigrating right right between these
two okay and then the lobby ask can we
give examples of two of each other
that's exactly why I did it this way the
lodging so will I'm too getting to that
okay
so monitoring and let's start with
monitoring and performance okay so when
monitoring you have to be able to
monitor both the application
the framework and/or the hardware
okay so the application itself ie the
code that you created your hardware
and/or framework so what is what I mean
my framework like Hadoop is a framework
that allows you to perform certain
functions that your code may accomplish
right so your code can use Hadoop it can
use MapReduce it can use these other
tools to perform a certain function
right so you not only need need to
monitor your application that's using
the framework but you also need to
monitor that the brain work itself that
it's using and then that framework is
installed on several servers so if you
were to look at it from a perspective
this is probably the perspective to look
at it from okay so
so this may be your your architecture
right here I'm using your service that
that your application is running on okay
so all this only on these set of servers
map atlas cookies look further over here
on this set of service I mean let's just
go server one server to and server 3 all
this set of applicable on to the farad's
you have a month of these service but
then you may have an app you may have a
framework we have the Hadoop
each loop a file data file system we
have this right and that HDFS as call is
deployed across multiple service so not
only do you need to monitor the servers
but you also need to monitor your
framework and then what you might have
excuse me you may have
another set of service
and let's just call the server for
excuse me
server server for and server pipe and
you may have this and this is where your
application resides
all right this is where it this is this
is where it's all and then what happens
is is that new
you
you need to be able to kind of talk to
both of those right from the application
to better court to the hdfs so what's
going to happen is today you're going to
monitor
all of the hardware to check out your IO
but things you got to monitor your your
your framework to include HDFS and a lot
of times these frameworks have their own
monitoring tools and then you're going
to have to monitor your application now
the crazy thing about it is nobody three
separate monitoring tools you go from
monitor 1 1 2 2 2 - 2 3 to see how all
of these things are going on right so
there are some tools that are better at
doing that now we can't get into all the
specifics I just want to kind of show
you if there's some tools that are out
there ok so one of the tools that can be
used to do that is not non view core mmm
oh yeah so one of the tools that are
often used no matter where you go is not
yet alright and what we can't get into
the since about it but I will say rocky
Ellison is the Nagios for is an open
source tool that allows you to download
with limited capability right and but a
lot of time with these services in order
for you to get other things they have
other paid products to be used to
increase your capability okay so and
then probably other thing that's worth
noting there are like thousands of
Nagios plugins you be used with Nagios
so that's the power of Nagios because
there's a big community behind Nagios
that will often simply share their
plugins that they have developed and
written alright but at the core it's
kind of made to kind of monitor your
your your architecture and and if you
would oh s related type things ok so
that's not reals now another one that is
probably worth mentioning is you may
have heard of it is
elastic search hello Amy
I'm going to put these tools in the chat
box so if we want to go back to them you
can okay so another one is probably
we're looking at is elasticsearch now
again now things like this require a
little bit more development to really
kind of make it work and effect it but
unless it's a great tool and this is the
one that I built personally and I like
it better than Nagios because it's
easier to integrate
the the application monitoring the
framework monitoring and the hardware
monitoring as a part of that it is a lot
easier to me and then from there you can
then begin to build analytics that kind
of one to determine how these low you
know when something breaks identify when
it breaks so that you take action right
probably one of the main issues with
HDFS is input/output right your ability
to read and write so as HDFS writes to
disk sometimes you have these disk
bottlenecks excusing where it's not
writing fast enough or whether it's not
read that's enough so yo TAS how do we
define framework when it comes to
multiple technologies in our
applications involved like the
application mainframe um so yeah back in
so here's what I would say often when I
think of frameworks I don't necessarily
think about the middleware portion quite
honestly or even Java for that matter
right typically when I think of
frameworks
I think of frameworks that allow you to
perform some functionality or most parts
like some database framework that will
across its distributed so if you would
you may have a piece that one will serve
a once over two or three to five and
together they work to accomplish a
particular and our particular something
I think of that as a framework when it
comes to XML job uh applications and
mainframes cetera all those can can be
used to implement a particular framework
right so I don't necessarily consider
those things as the framework I think
frameworks are probably a distraction
above what you just mentioned so I also
see that Schmitt I ask the question can
obvious be used on Windows I think the
answer is yes although I'm not 107
positive about that one yeah I think so
yeah
yeah it is now I what I don't know is it
they charge for that one I'm not sure
about that let's buy some people look
into
alright our move on alright and that
research so elasticsearch is its in
itself it really is a like an index
database tool it takes data index little
center Center right but the cool thing
about some of the things that you have
available most people is these products
so the electric electric search is the
core of the product but you also have
Kabana and what obama is is that it's a
visualization tool that's very similar
so to be asked but I can few questions
in minutes middle so Jim Cabana is a
visualization tool that allows him to do
a lot a lot of different things whether
it's kind of make some quick query can
create analytics and it interested
really just a nice great tool it also
does time series data which you know
logs are time series related right
you can do graph relationships all kind
of coolness with Kabam so come on if you
would is the visualization tool that the
developer to use to get insight to their
architecture now with that being said
unless your search is what with index
the data ok now this tool called beats
beats of these these things a lot of
these are free now beats provide these
different would be different packages
they call them beep they apply the
packages across different types package
of these packages do different things
right so what you can do is I can take
these different beats and apply them on
a particular server and then those beats
will grab what it makes they have and
send them to a central elasticsearch
repository
right so let's just look at this the
beat family so I can look at log files
with POW beat and these log files are
often was you know different framework
security things they use those log files
to record what something's going on and
you can send those at with with low
latency to an election search database
additionally there's other various
metrics you can measure for there's
Network data you can look at that's
window.event logs as well as your uptime
as well all of these things can be used
essentially viewed and coordinated with
in elasticsearch this is why I
personally this is why I prefer this
tool because it's open source number one
and I don't have to pay a cost to really
kind of build these things outside of
just about the time
so it is recommended for much data into
the application like e-commerce domains
for example well so I I wouldn't be
careful with this because elasticsearch
it works really well like we have a lot
of notes like you know thousands of
thousands of notes and there are all
kind of a small execution of something
going on in a shtetl all the time and it
works fine but he left asserts itself at
some point as far as it isn't still up
too like a petabyte scale right so the
answer is that it's 400 data into the
applications I this it has the data
applicant interested application itself
doesn't necessarily have anything to do
with less and search with less as far as
the context in which I'm speaking about
left to search it left a search just
simply grab whatever law whatever
performance criteria you you're putting
out and moves it over to elect research
for process but it's a whole different
conversation if we want to run those
data into the applications all of you
left to search all right
all right so again
so again those just a few about the
monitoring performance other things they
include releasing it for into production
so the next monitoring performance we've
taken care of that piece
now who multiple you commit to
production and I got to kind of try to
hurry up a little bit now moving into
production there's several tools that
you can use for that one of them I would
probably recommend and again it the
things I recommend are primarily open
source like that and so ansible is a
great tool and there's another one
called salt stack
both of these are similar tools you may
have heard the most popular just to kind
of put it out there yes chef yes the
actually shaft above it yet exactly
these are these are some of the tools
again without getting into the specifics
you know damn it
is this quite a quite a few tools tools
out there they are similar they're
simple they are similar similarly kind
of built in a goal is to kind of move
along this line of will taking this this
this code and once it happened it is
built deploying it into production and
it's like several other one-off type
things you can use as well these are
some of the more popular ones there's a
mean is always the best but it's one of
the more popular ones that these tools
do a great job of not only releasing
into production but also automating a
lot of your tasks to include
configuration management right so if you
would the tool on the left hand side
listen to production separation
management those are great tools be used
in order to do that okay now for I think
probably one of the the top tools they
use for building and packaging is a tool
called Jenkins and I'm sure many of you
have heard of that again another open
source tool they have a paid version for
this but they have thousands of plugins
the bill as well as the large community
this this tool can be used to automate
the integration and season is set up way
for building applications in integrated
performance if you would this is what we
talked about earlier these two building
applications and integration of
performance testing Jenkins provides
pipelines allow you to do that to ensure
continuous integration and continuous
delivery and then other tools like
Jenkins one that begins with a H then
I'm kind of drawing a blank on I'll
think about it here in a minute and now
provided to you what other tools like
ink is out there and they
our open source for could code
development in unit testing the unit
testing runs well with women with
Dinkins but you have to write the test
first right so the developers have to
definitely understand the unit testing
librarian the unit testing mechanism
Nords to properly write the test like I
personally have moved from unit testing
where I was using J unit for Java unit
testing and now they kind of have this
they moved to a format that allows you
to create answer files for your testing
not so much just simply about testing
each functional point of functionality
but it's uh more about really truly
measuring the output of your code and
what that needs to ensure that a
something is working so Pilate asked a
question can puppet itself be installed
on Mac machines I'm not sure Bellotti
quite honestly I just never really had
to do that so I just I'm not sure I know
salt a Nashville can but I almost
certainly can be because the whole point
of them is to be OS agnostic um but I'll
put that out to the class if you wanna
have to deploy a puppet of chef on Macs
before yeah so but like I think the
answer is yes but I will have to verify
that so I'll put that down as one of my
questions to answer so another question
Jerome they asked the question Thank You
Schmidt of some public can go on that
excellent do I have tools that you read
can recommend for CIS EB for dotnet
Windows and John the Linux so I've done
a lot of questions excellent so the
question is do we have tools that you
recommend for CI continuous integration
to use development for talk net Windows
and Java Linux so I know Jenkins is a
great tool for continuous integration
axioms development
delivery's guilty or java for not what
my experiences is is Linux quite
honestly um that's not somebody on the
window side but I I'm almost certain
that Jenkins can also run on Windows as
well yeah thank you so does but dotnet
so um so bit of talk about it not a
windows if you already have it well TFS
then you might think of that excellent
okay
alright another one they did to talk
about was team city right that's a
tillage a pirate all correct right till
the hour jetbrains
Oh
mmm listen yeah so did it bring the baby
rebel team City and it works with King
and Grayson out the box but not
necessarily contains delivery but it
might be worthwhile in their many
options out if everyone again I'm just
kind of putting a few of them out there
so that you kind of know where to go to
hell fine some of those okay all right
oh where am I
all right um packing the application of
what
and so for deep he also did something to
as well uh after meet you
people electric is are you translated
electric thank you all right if I fall
okay so I prefer deep recommended
perhaps electric clout for seamless
delivery so next I've heard of that but
that's a surprise something worth
looking into
alright alright lastly um coal
development and unit testing so for coal
development I would recommend like
probably the most common thing that
almost every developer team uses thank
you for people that for the URL
appreciate that
probably one of the main ones ago I've
hit my time this github.com
um github provides enterprise level
support for you and there's other tools
that go along with github for for
packaging up your software and version
control github and then there's another
one an Atlantian product called this not
bitmoji I'm sorry
yes thanks so yeah II guess network so
they got big Huskies was talking about
yeah big bucket stash was the previous
one
Balaji that they used but this bucket is
kind of the latest version of that and
so they had available for you as well
and stash I think is the older version
of this bucket all right um I think I've
hit my limit everyone so got it
so as you can see there are a large
variety of tools that we can use to
excuse me
a large variety of tools that we can use
to to work through everything hopefully
show from the ashes getting up an editor
like Eclipse Sunday github is it's not
an IDE like eclipse or the integrated
development environment it is not github
just kind of keeps track of versions and
it allows you to immigrate code it like
to control what is able to be placed in
a release
all right control what the datums so you
everybody Smith there code and then you
can say I want this code this code this
codes be included as a part of this
relief
to work through it
all right so uh
Thank You bellotti that's great way to
give weight but it is very control tool
to manage code of the developer to have
one location or even multiple locations
so excellent
I'm afraid with dimension Sanjay the
butt
however you probably right so I saw a
question here they talked about it
possible for questioning
okay it's a Schmidt I - this strings
haven't each the answers question if a
tool opens words were controlled AMC and
integrate okay guys all right so I think
this will conclude our session for today
again hopefully you found this session
useful hey once become an expert in
cloud computing then subscribe to
simpler Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here